[Music]
spirit obtains this actuality here
because the extremes of which it is the
unity are also directly determined as
being actualities on their own account
their unity is broken up into two rigid
unyielding science each of which is for
the other an actual object excluded from
it consequently that unity appears as a
middle term which is excluded and
distinct from the separated actual
existence of the sides it has therefore
itself as an actual objective existence
distinct from its sides and as reality
for them that is is something that
exists the spiritual substance enters as
such into existence only when it is
gained for its two sides self
consciousness which no this pure self is
an actual existence having immediate
validity and in knowing this are also
immediately aware that they are such
actual actual existences only through
the mediation of their self alienation
through that pure self the moments of
substance are so far purified has to be
the self knowing category and thus to be
moments of spirit through this mediation
spirit comes to exist qua spirit as a
reality it is thus the middle term which
presupposes those extremes and is
created by their existence but equally
it is the spiritual whole issuing forth
between them which sunders itself into
them and only by means of this contact
creates each into the whole in terms of
its own principle the fact that both
extremes are already implicitly reduced
to moments and set apart produces their
unity and this is the process which
brings both into a unity interchanges
their determinations and unites them in
each extreme this mediation is the spa's
it's the notion of each of the two
extremes in its actuality or makes what
each is in itself into its spirit
paragraph 509 is pretty densely
metaphysical and you might say
methodological on Hegel's part so
there's a good bit here for us to unpack
particularly just in terms of the
language that he's using and and what is
happening here remember back to the
previous paragraph 508 where where a lot
of what Hagel had to say was in terms of
language and you want to look ahead to
what is going on in paragraph 511 and a
little bit later where Hagel is going to
return once again to language or
linguistic phenomena and keep in mind
that what we're talking about here
really is the interplay between two
poles and Hagel is gonna be talking here
about what's what's connecting them
what's mediating them what is providing
them with a certain kind of unity but
it's not a unity that that collapses all
of them into the same thing rather what
we're talking about here is a dynamic
unity so what does Hagel say in this
text he says spirit obtains this
actuality and that's that actuality is
really one of the core ideas running
throughout this this section things
exist as actuality as having a worldly
presence this is part of why Hagel is
you know so focused on human history
ideas matter insofar as they take shape
through history indeterminate forms
concrete ways of life commitments that
people make and then see where they go
so he says spirit obtains this actuality
here at this point because the extremes
what are the extremes the end points the
the parts that are being viewed as
what's really going on these extremes he
says are of which it is the unity spirit
is the unity are directly determined as
being actualities on their own account
so not just actualities
for somebody else actualities on their
own account now I want to pause here for
just a second think back to one of the
points that Hegel was making earlier on
in this section and also in several
other sections where you've got this
this sort of you know two extremes what
are the extremes by the way I don't have
them here on the board we're talking
essentially about state power and the
noble consciousness and spirit is
somehow mediating the two of them now
the noble consciousness is you could say
for itself it is actual it is a real
person or persons or a class of persons
the nobles and it exists it has worldly
presence and it understands itself as
such it experiences itself as such what
about state power state power is there
to be recognized by everybody involved
is state power conscious of itself as
state power at this point in the
dialectic Hegel is saying yes it is
recognizing itself as an actuality in
its own right both of them also
recognize each other as actualities
other actualities that they're related
to and there's something that is
unifying them which is Hegel is calling
spirit here right so he says their unity
spirit is broken up into two rigid
unyielding sides each of which is for
the other an actual object excluded from
it have we seen this dynamic before yes
we indeed have both of them are miss
recognizing what is going on in this
situation neither of them is fully
conscious of the fact that they are
connected together by this unity by a
middle term each of them
views the other as something that is not
it something that is excluding it so
state power on the one side the noble
consciousness on the other side they
exist for themselves also in themselves
and in relation to the other but the
other by opposition this is a strange
way to talk at this point because as we
know the noble consciousness is the
noble consciousness precisely by
identifying itself with the state power
by you might say willfully subordinating
itself sacrificing its own self but as
we've seen that's not all there is to
the story so Hegel goes on and he says
the unity appears as a middle term the
unity of spirit mind consciousness
consciousness in its full sense not
possessed either by the state or by the
noble consciousness but something a
third over and above them he says this
is excluded and distinct from the
separated actual existence of the sides
now that is really interesting isn't it
to say that it is not only the case that
these are excluding each other but
they're also excluding this third term
something new is entering into the
process and it's entering into the
process as an actuality as yet another
actuality unless I put here actuality to
also actuality we might say so we have
yes and no or one and zero and then
another something else so he goes on and
he says here we go it has therefore an
actual objective existence distinct from
its sides and has reality for them that
is it is something that exists how might
we conceptualize this for ourselves
the sides are aware that the opposition
of themselves to the other extreme is
not all there is in the picture can they
make sense of this for themselves we're
gonna see this talked about at the very
end of this paragraph aren't we so he
goes on and he says the spiritual
substance enters into existence only
when it is gained for its two sides
self-consciousness --is which no this
pure self as an actual existence so now
these two sides are no longer just
extremes that exist for consciousness
here and it's not just that there's
self-consciousness on this side and
state power on this side both of these
have become now self-consciousness and
we have to explore well how can state
power itself be a self-consciousness and
that's not answered here in this
paragraph but it will be in the
paragraphs yet to come so coming back to
this he says the spiritual substance
enters into existence when it's gained
for its two sides self-consciousness
--is which no this pure self as an
actual existence having immediate
validity so they grasp this unity which
they are not but which you could say is
them and unites them together and brings
them into something greater than
themselves he goes on and he says two
just to finish this sentence in knowing
this are also immediately aware that
they are such actual existences only
through the mediation of their self
alienation both sides are being or
becoming rather conscious of the fact
that there's something else involved
here that they cannot encompass
something else that they cannot dominate
it's not just that they're missing out
on what the other side is so that for
example the state power might look at
the noble consciousness and perhaps even
feel a sense of jealousy or envy towards
it or something similar may be going on
on the part of the noble consciousness
where it obeys the state power but
thinks you know maybe I could do this
job better and maybe they're not really
getting me but the third term is also
which is uniting them is uniting them in
a consciousness of their self alienation
they are not only alienated from each
other they're also alienated from
themselves so we have a very complex
picture here don't we in this this
discussion in this paragraph now that's
not all there is going on Hegel goes on
and he says that it's through that pure
self the moments of the substance are so
far purified as to be the self knowing
category we see Hegel over and over
again talking in ethical terms about the
category about what it is that's going
to encompass everything right so the
self knowing category and thus to be
moments of spirit through this mediation
spirit comes to exist qua spirit as
reality this is really a very important
point a crux in this development spirit
this is the phenomenology of spirit
right the phenomenology of Geist of mind
of spirit of you know what is driving
history what is trying to come to full
consciousness of itself it has to do so
through actual izing itself not just
through you know an Aristotelian mind
thinking itself but through actualizing
itself in the world in relation to these
other actualities that is part of what
Hegel means by the term spirit that's
part of why I think in English I mean
neither spirit nor mind is really a
satisfactory translation of Geist in
this case right because the you know
we're leaving one thing out or leaving
another thing out Hegel's idealism is a
pragmatic engagement with reality at
least at points like this in the
dialectic so he goes on and
says it's the the middle term which
presupposes those extremes and is
created by their existence so in a way
spirit at this point in time is coming
into existence becoming something
worldly becoming something manifest that
people can see as spirit because of the
interplay between these extremes their
lack of identity the slippage between
them right so spirit arises through that
spirit becomes actual an existent
through that he says that it's equally
the spiritual whole issuing forth
between them it provides them with a
unity now remember that Hegel has just
finished telling us about language I'd
mentioned in the previous paragraphs
commentary that we're not getting a
general theory of language here but
spirit is working through language to
provide this you might say milieu in
which these these things can play
themselves out so he goes on and he says
that it's the spiritual whole issuing
forth between them which sunders itself
into them and only by means of this
contact creates each into the whole in
terms of its own principle it recognizes
what each is you could say so he says
both of these extremes are reduced to
moments and set apart this is what
produces their unity Hegel is going to
close here by talking about the notion
the concept the buchaiah
right he says this mediation posits it
sets forth the notion of each in of the
two extremes in its actuality or makes
what each is in itself into its spirit
so what is it this is that you know
again a quija galleon point what is it
to have a notion as opposed to having a
mere understanding or a con you know a
concept not in the Hegelian sense but in
you know the the previous senses of the
term it's to recognize how all of these
are connected together
and that is what spirit is doing so
we've got this very you know abstract
very metaphysical passage that's what's
going on here and now we're going to be
able to turn our attention back to some
things that we can actually tie in you
know with with well actualities you know
it's one thing to talk about actuality
in the abstract it's another thing to
actually see in actuality as such
the two extremes the state power and the
noble consciousness are split up by the
land of the state power into the
abstract Universal which is obeyed and
into the self-centered will which
however does not yet conform to the
universal now the noble consciousness
into the obedience rendered by the
existence which is not self-centered or
the intrinsic being of self-respect and
honor and into the still on the
surrendered being for itself the will
that still reserves its independence the
two moments into which both sides are
purified in which therefore our moments
of language are the abstract universal
called the general good and the pure
self which in serving the state
renounced its own many and various
interests both are essentially the same
from pure self is just the abstract
universal and consequently their unity
is expressed as their middle term but
the soft it is at first actual only
unconsciousness in the one extreme while
the in itself is actual only in the
state power the other extreme what
consciousness lacks is the actual
transference to it of the state power
that merely in the form of honor and
what is lacking in the state power is
that it should be obeyed that merely is
the so called general good but his will
or that it should have now the self of
the power of decision the unity of the
notion in which the state power still
stands it into which consciousness has
been purified becomes actual in this
process of mediation the simple
existence of which is middle term is
language however the sides of the unity
are not yet solves which exists as
selves for the state power has yet to be
energized into a self this language is
therefore not yet spirit that completely
knows and expresses itself
paragraph 510 now introduces a bit more
concreteness into the discussion from
the previous paragraph which was a
little abstract and now we're actually
getting some some things that we can
identify here the state power the noble
consciousness remember that we have as
the mediating term for both of these
spirit and we have the notion or concept
the McGriff bringing them together and
Hegel is charting out for us the process
of its development so he tells us that
these these two extremes right are being
split up into their own twos they're
being bifurcated within remember that he
said that they were self alien and not
only are they alienated from each other
and unified through through spirit but
they were also you might say split
broken asunder within themselves and
here Hegel is going to tell us about how
two of the sides are within these are
really sort of working behind the scenes
and then there's what we could call the
public face right and so the state power
is broken up into the abstract Universal
which as he says is once demands and
gets obedience and then a self-centered
will what is this self-centered will
he's going to talk about this a bit more
in the next paragraphs but we might
think here about you know who's actually
in charge who calls the shots within the
government that represents state power
and so we have you know a sort of
relation here within and then on the
side of the noble consciousness as we
remember back several paragraphs before
it wasn't all just sacrifice and
obedience and thereby getting
self-respect for for itself and honor
there was also another side the unser
entered being for itself as as he called
it right the noble holds something back
and insofar as the noble holds something
back they're not completely noble but if
they didn't hold something back they
really wouldn't be a person in a sense
they would become their own abstraction
wouldn't they this is a a tension within
this entire dynamic and likewise over
here if the government is all just
entirely abstract universal you know the
government existing for everybody the
totality and there's nobody who actually
has a corner office or who gets to sleep
in their office and wake up and you know
have breakfast brought to them so they
can start conducting affairs of state
you don't really have state power so
there has to be this you might say
behind the scenes aspect or dimension to
it in order for it to work and what we
see most of the time what what people
focus upon is the relation between these
two sides of the noble consciousness and
state power the the state and its
servitors who are elevated by serving
and so Hegel is going to tell us here
that after these these are split up
right he says these two moments into
which both sides are purified and which
therefore our moments of language are
the abstract Universal called the
general good and the pure self with in
which in serving the state renounced its
own many and various interests so this
is what we talk about the general good
and the pure self and there's there's an
exchange going on here as well between
these and interchange by giving
obedience to the general good to the AB
tract universal to the state the noble
individual gets back honor from the
state also to some degree participates
you might say in its power you become a
minister or a general or whatever the
one who does the dirty work perhaps even
so he goes on and he says this is
happening in language right he says both
are essentially the same both of these
are essentially the same why he says the
pure self is just the abstract universal
and consequently their unity is
expressed as their middle term this is
where spirit is tying things together
right to bring bring us back to what was
talked about in the last paragraph so he
says the self is that first actual only
in consciousness in the one extreme
while the in itself is actual only in
the state power the other extreme so
this isn't completely worked out yet
these two sides are fusing together in a
certain way but they're not completely
there so he says what consciousness
lacks is the actual transference to it
of the state power not merely in the
form of honor see the the possession of
something from the state power is always
contingent you could have your your
position remove the state power can can
exile you can push you aside so it's not
yet within the possession of the noble
is it it's actually in the possession of
the self-centered will but we're not
talking about that quite yet are we so
he goes on and he says consciousness
lacks the actual transference of the
state power not merely in the form of
honor and what is lacking in the state
power is that it should be obeyed not
merely as a so-called general good but
as will that it should endow the self
with the power of decision so there's
kind of a things not completely adding
up here going on the general good
draws things to it it tells you what you
ought to do but what actually makes
decisions what actually determines is
the will that's not yet represented here
Hegel goes on and he says the unity of
the notion in which the state power
still stands and into which
consciousness has been purified becomes
actual in this process of mediation what
is mediation this is a term that we
throw around a lot in the Hegelian
system and in the the development of
consciousness here in in the the
dialectic of the phenomenology of spirit
isn't it what is mediation we could go
back to the preface and look at that
it's really having something else that
is required that has a role that exerts
itself within there it can be a middle
term or these can be mediating each
other there can be self mediation but
the point is one way of thinking about
mediation is nothing is ever as simple
as it looks there's always some in flux
there's always some contribution by
something else so he goes on and he says
this process of mediation the simple
existence of which as middle term is
language so once again we come back to
language Hegel is talked about this as
being within the realm of language and
now the mediation that's going to take
place the you might say bringing these
things together this is gonna have to be
brought into language and this is going
to have to be brought into language how
is that going to happen it's not all
happening here this is going to happen
in subsequent paragraphs so he brings us
to a close by saying the sides of the
unity are not yet selves which exist
itself state power has yet to be
energized into itself it still has to
have this self centered will having its
role this language he says is therefore
not yet spirit that completely knows and
expresses itself and yet here's what
he's not
it is spirits this is the process by
which spirit comes to know itself and
language plays a role
you